ja wir sind zurück in der stadthalle in
riesa und wie das so üblich ist bei uns
zum morgen beginnen wenn wir dann im
interview bei uns es bernd baumann der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der fdp-bundestagsfraktion
baumann man bricht ja keine
vertraulichkeiten man sagt dass die
fraktion ja durchaus heterogen ist
welche erwartungshaltung haben sie denn
jetzt an den parteitag denn vieles was
hier beschlossen wird das soll ja dann
auch in ihr auftreten in den bundestag
einfließen das ist im grunde auch ein
parteitag der selbstvergewisserung dass
wir in vielen punkten weswegen wir uns
gegründet hatten jetzt auch wirklich
recht behalten haben wenn sie nur mal
angucken die aktuelle
inflationsentwicklung wir sind ja
gegründet worden unter anderem wegen der
europäischen zentralbank und dem
misstrauen gegen die auflösung des euro
und genau das erlebt wir jetzt
inflationsraten von acht prozent du
lieber gott die schweiz hat 2,6 prozent
die macht eine stabilitätspolitik wie
die alte bundesbahn da wären wir mit
einer vernünftigen politik also der der
euro ist hat sich eine art und weise
entwickelt dass er zu lira wird sie
recht behalten das ist nicht unbedingt
jetzt geht auf die ampel koalition hat
die vorgehenden koalition zurück sondern
es geht vor allem die krone pandemie und
jetzt auch der krieg gegen die ukraine
ist ja ein wesentlicher beschleuniger
dieser entwicklung ihrer volkswirt ich
weiß ich sie vielleicht auch eine
inflation braucht immer sozusagen
konkreten realwirtschaftlichen anlass
aber auch eine monetäre geldbasis also
eine geldvermehrung und die ezb hat 4
billion millionen gedruckt und
staatsschulden auch zu kaufen was nie
hätte passieren dürfen nach den
verträgen das ist passiert wie als
einziger davor gewarnt alle anderen
haben mitgemacht haben das unkritisch
begleitet die fdp so ein bisschen mal
aber hat auch mitgemacht da haben wir
recht behalten genauso wie bei der
energiepolitik und vielen anderen das
ist ein parteitag der
selbstvergewisserung aber die ezb
politik wird ja in der tat auch
kritisiert die hat ja dazu auch
beigetragen zu der jetzigen situation
schauen wir mal auf die fraktionen da
gab es ja aus der fraktion heraus kritik
an tino copala dem alten und
möglicherweise auch neue parteichef an
seinem führungsstil an der ost
orientierung der partei auch an der
erhaltung der unkritischen haltung
gegenüber russland stimmt es also doch
was alexander gauland mal gesagt hat
dass auch die bundestagsfraktion
einjähriger haufen ist wir sind jetzt im
fünften jahr ich bin erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer die
ganzen jahre gewesen meine aufgabe ist
es auch die truppen dort
zusammenzuhalten von woche zu woche das
alles abzustimmen und das hat im
nachhinein doch super funktioniert
gucken sie sich doch die anderen
fraktionen an die linken was da passiert
ist dass ich es explodiert die krise die
die cdu hatte der märz ist doch
mindestens umstritten wie die wie andere
fraktionschefs auch innerhalb der
fraktion das ist überall spannungsbögen
überall gibt es verschiedene flügel und
man muss sich immer von woche zu woche
thematisch einigen ich glaube da liegen
wir sehr gut und sehr stabil jetzt im
fünften jahr bin übrigens jetzt der
dienstälteste erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer aller fraktionen im
bundestag da sehen sie auch eine gewisse
stabilität jetzt sitzt ihnen die
schwäche der anderen parteien nicht
unbedingt etwas auf der anderen
fraktionen wenn sie sehen wie die
landtagswahlen letzten monat für die afg
ausgegangen sind bleiben wir noch mal
bei dem thema ukraine krieg kriegen
überfall auf die ukraine die afg hat und
ja so eine art distanz politik ukraine
russland jetzt hat allerdings der die
bundestagsfraktion die hälfte aller
anwesenden bundestagsabgeordneten fdh
dem sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr zugestimmt
die andere hälfte hat es abgelehnt ist
da auch ein bisschen die position von
tino keller geschwächt worden in der
bundestagsfraktion nein das ist eine
inhaltliche frage wir sind und auch das
darf ich noch mal sagen seit jahren die
fraktion gewesen die am meisten hinter
der bundeswehr stand daher kommt ja dass
wir so viele hohe offiziere in unseren
reihen haben drei sterne general ist in
unseren reihen ist afd abgeordneter wir
waren immer für die bundeswehr nur
dieses konstrukt irgendwie das
grundgesetz zu ändern und nicht mit
solide haushaltspolitik die bundeswehr
solide finanzieren hat die die er
haushalts prinzipien in den vordergrund
gestellt haben aber die wollten auch die
bundeswehr unterstützen haben sie die
grundgesetzänderung das ist nix und die
die gesagt haben der bundeswehr muss auf
jeden fall unterstützt werden selbst mit
seinem homunculus wie diesem
haushaltspolitischen verdrehungen und
und schattenhaushalten und so das war
sozusagen die disparität was man jetzt
höher gewichtet weil wir sind alle zu
100 prozent für die bundeswehr dieser
finanzierung stil der war ein bisschen
wie bios aber warum sind sie wenn sie
die partei der soldaten sind eigentlich
gegen waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
wenn putin die ukraine ganz platt macht
dann ist auch deutschland militärisch in
gefahr und das ist für die bundeswehr
dann ein riesenproblem denn wir sind
nicht besonders gut aufgestellt ist
warum sind sie gegen ein engagement
deutschlands in der ukraine es gibt ja
also wir sind nicht gegen jedes
engagement wir sind für hilfe sozusagen
jeder art und wir leisten haben
milliarden hilfe in jeder form die
ukraine wäre wahrscheinlich schon lange
zusammen gebrochen und unsere hilfen
finanziell sozusagen versorgungs metro
krankenhaus alles was man da bedarf und
auch waffen sind das schon geliefert
worden und sie ist glaube ich nicht so
wie sie es gerade formulierten dass
soldaten der see für waffenlieferungen
sind das überhaupt nicht der fall wir
haben wie gesagt und drei sterne general
der das kritisch sieht und wenn sie den
brigadegeneral fatima nehmen der die
frau merkel beraten hat als sie noch
kanzlerin war der sieht das auch sehr
kritisch wir müssen einfach und darauf
kommt es an um diesen konflikt zu lösen
uns nicht auf militärische verengen und
da ist die lösung suchen sondern in
deutschland ist das größte land europas
und russland ist das größte land der
welt und ohne russland gibt es kein
frieden und keine sicherheit in europa
seit jahrhunderten nicht und wird in
jahrhundert noch so sein und das größte
land westeuropas muss vielmehr
diplomatische initiativen erreichen im
hinblick auf eine lösung des gesamt
problems und wenn sie beispielsweise den
dohnanyi von der spd nehmen er sagt der
schlüssel für die ukraine nicht nicht in
moskau nicht in der ukraine liegt in der
usa das heißt in der herstellung
sozusagen diplomatische krisen
bewältigung einer krise die sich so
zugespitzt hat dass putin
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg begonnen
hat das ist nicht zu rechtfertigen aber
die krise die feuer entstanden ist und
die so zu entladen werden muss wo es
neue friedensordnung geben muss das ist
darüber worauf wir uns gewaltig putin
kannst doch einstellung frieden mit
russland kann es doch nur ohne putin
geben oder können sie sich was forscher
entscheidende die russen sozusagen wenn
das lange zeit möglicherweise keine
friedensordnung geben dass auch putin
hat ja kann ja kein interesse daran
haben und auch die russischen eliten die
putin noch stützen dass sie sich da
permanent abnutzen das wird eine art von
von trieben geben und das muss eben eine
friedenslösung sein die nicht nur
zwischen ukraine und russland ist das
ist überhaupt nicht handhabbar das muss
so zu einer welt friedensordnung geben
wie es früher auch mal war wo ganz klar
ist russland hat dem platz die nato
macht dies und das und das sind die
grenzen und alle fühlen sich wieder
sicher ist dann muss es wenn wir noch
zeit hätten könne über den zeitkorridor
sprechen in dem das ich realisierte er
wird möglicherweise sehr lange dauern
ganz baumann im phoenix interview danke
dass sie dabei bedanke mich